because it means
everything to you.
♪
>> YOU ENME WITH THE PRESIDENCY,
I WILL DRAW ON THE BEST OF US,
NOT THE WORST.
I’LL BE AN ALLY OF THE LIGHT,
NOT THE DARKNESS.
UNITED, WE CAN AND WILL OVERCOME
THIS SEASON OF DARKNESS IN
AMERICA.
WE’LL CHOOSE HOPE OVER FEAR,
FACTS OVER FICTION, FAIRNESS
OVER PRIVILEGE.
PETE: THAT WAS JOE BIDEN READING
REALLY BIG FONT.
REMEMBER WHEN JOE BIDEN PROMISED
HOPE AND OPTIMISM IN WELL, JUST
SIX MONTHS INTO HIS PRESIDENCY,
OPTIMISM IS AT AN ALL-TIME LOW.
A BRAND NEW POLL COMING OUT JUST
NOW SHOWS THAT 55% OF THE PUBLIC
ARE PESSIMISTIC ABOUT WHERE THE
COUNTRY IS HEADED.
A 20-POINT DECLINE FROM APRIL.
THAT’S AN ABC NEWS POLL.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP
IS HERE TO REACT.
LARA, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE THIS MORNING.
THOSE NUMBERS BRAND NEW.
DO THEY SURPRISE YOU AT ALL?
>> NO.
I’M ACTUALLY SURPRISED THEY’RE
NOT WORSE THAN THAT.
IT HAS REALLY BECOME CLEAR THAT
PEOPLE HAVE MAJOR BUYER’S
REMORSE WITH OUR MOST POPULAR
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF
AMERICA, 81 MILLION VOTES,
REMEMBER, GUYS.
I SAY THAT FACETIOUSLY --
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
PETE: THEY COULDN’T EVEN FILL A
SMALL AUDITORIUM.
>> RIGHT.
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT, I MEAN, THE REALITY IS IT’S
ONLY TAKEN SIX MONTHS FOR JOE
BIDEN ALONGSIDE KAMALA HARRIS TO
REALLY START TO RUN AMERICA
STRAIGHT INTO THE GROUND.
YOU SEE HOW QUICKLY WE HAVE HAD
GAS PRICES SKYROCKETING, MASSIVE
INFLATION.
THE REALITY IS THAT WE ARE
PAYING PEOPLE TO STAY THE HOME
INSTEAD OF GOING TO WORK.
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE HAVING A
REALLY HARD TIME COMING BACK
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE LOOKING WEAK NOW IN THE
EYES OF NOT JUST OUR
ADVERSARIES, BUT OUR ALLIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE HAVE HAD AT LEAST A MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FLOW OVER OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, AND THAT’S JUST
WHAT WE KNOW OF.
NOW SIX MONTHS INTO THE
BIDEN/HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO, NO, I’M NOT SURPRISED THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE PESSIMISTIC ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA.
AND HOW SAD BECAUSE IT WASN’T
TOO LONG AGO UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP THAT THIS WAS ALL
REVERSED.
IT WAS THE OTHER WAY.
PEOPLE WERE VERY ON OPTIMISTIC.
THERE WERE JOBS FLOURISHING, WE
FELT VERY POSITIVE ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA AND NOW HERE
WE ARE.
IS SO REALLY SAD.
BUT, AGAIN, NOT SURPRISING.
WE KIND OF KNEW IF YOU GAVE THE
REINS TO A MAN LIKE JOE BIDEN
WHO HAS A HARD TIME FIGURING OUT
EXACTLY WHERE HE IS, THIS IS THE
RESULT.
PETE: YEAH, FOR SURE.
AT LEAST WE DON’T HAVE THOSE
MEAN TWEETS, THAT’S THE BONUS,
YOU KNOW, THAT’S THE UPSIDE IS,
APPARENTLY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BUYER’S
REMORSE, WHAT ASPECT OF THAT,
WHAT POLICY DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
ARE MISSING THE MOST WHICH LEADS
TO THIS PESSIMISM WHICH, BY THE
WAY, PESSIMISM WHEN THE MEDIA IS
COVERING FOR HIM AT EVERY STEP
ALSO.
>> YEAH, IT’S TRUE.
WELL, I MEAN, I THINK IT’S
DIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
MY PARENTS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, AND I THE YELL THEY THAT
THEY -- CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY
ALONG WITH A LOT OF AMERICANS
HAVE HAD A LOT REALLY HARD TIME
FINDING WORKERS.
BACK TO THE POINT ABOUT PAYING
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE RESULTS OF
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO JUST FREE
FLOW OVER OUR SOUTHERN BOARD.
IT TRICKLES DOWN TO EVERY FACET
OF AMERICAN LIFE, OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM, OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
JOBS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE FACT THAT WE REALLY ARE JUST
NOT RESPECTED AGAIN, I THINK
ANYWHERE AROUND THE WORLD LIKE
WE WERE UNDER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP, HE EXUDED STRENGTH TO SO
MANY PEOPLE BIDE SEASON THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
HE’S VIEWED AS WEAKNESS AROUND
AMERICA.
WHENEVER WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
REENGAGING WITH IRAN AND THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL, WHEN WE GET
BACK WITH THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORDS, THINGS THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP STOOD UP TO AND SAID
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH, STANDING UP TO
CHINA AND OUR ADVERSARIES, YOUR
NOT SEEING THAT HAPPEN WITH JOE
BIDEN.
AND WHAT ABOUT JOE BEING THE
GREAT UNITER OF PEOPLE?
IN FACT, WE HAVE SEEN THE
SKYROCKETING CRIME, YOU KNOW,
THE MURDERS GOING THROUGH THE
ROOF ALL OVER OUR MAJOR AMERICAN
CITIES.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BRING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER, JOE?
INSTEAD, THE OPPOSITE HAS
HAPPENED --
PETE: UNITED CAN ONLY PASS
THINGS WITH RECONCILIATION IN
THE U.S. SENATE.
REAL QUICK, JUST GOT INFORMATION
THAT WE KNOW JOE BIDEN STOPPED
BUILDING THE WALL.
WHAT WE DIDN’T KNOW IS THAT IT
COST AMERICAN TAXPAYERS $2
BILLION SO FAR NOT TO BUILD THE
WALL, $3 MILLION A DAY.
SO APPARENTLY ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
US PAYING PEOPLE OR PAYING
CONTRACTS NOT TO, I DON’T KNOW,
BUILD THE WALL THAT WE NEED?
>> I MEAN, I’VE NEVER HEARD OF
SOMETHING MORE RIDICULOUS.
YOU KNOW, YOU GO DOWN TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND YOU SEE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD BUILT MOST
OF THE WALL.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS ALREADY PAID
FOR.
ALL JOE BIDEN HAD TO DO WAS
NOTHING, AND HE COULD HAVE JUST
SAT BACK, AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FINISHED.
BUT YOU HAVE THESE SMALL
SECTIONS OF WALL WHERE YOU HAVE
THE SUPPLIES LAID DOWN ON THE
GROUND.
ALL THEY’VE GOT TO DO IS STAND
THEM UP.
INSTEAD WE ARE PAYING, AS YOU
JUST SAID, $2 BILLION TO HAVE
SOMEBODY COME AND FORWARD THOSE
MATERIALS -- GUARD THOSE
MATERIALS INSTEAD OF ERECTING
THE WALL.
LOOK, YOU CAN DISPUTE A LOT OF
THINGS, BUT YOU CAN’T DISPUTE
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP WE HAD
REALLY, REALLY LOW NUMBERS OF
BORDER CROSSINGS.
HE HAD REVERSED THE SITUATION ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, AND NOW
UNDER JOE BIDEN WHAT A COMPLETE
AND TOTAL JOKE.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR
THIS AND, GUYS, THAT’S NOT EVEN
GOING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE’RE
PAYING TO BUS AND FLY THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AFTER THEY
CROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER TO ANY
CITY, USA.
IT IS ALSO COSTING US MILLIONS
AND PROBABLY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
PETE: WHO KNOWS WHAT THAT COST